僕の名前はうち。
僕の家はお金持ちなんだ。
[笑い]
私の家はお金持ちだから。じ、これ今日のお遣い。
お父様ありがとう。でもおりすぎていらないらない。
感字出した役もだ。始め
間違えた。汚れたからいらない。
これも
いらない。いらない。よ
しら
や100000だ。どやったら
やけ毎回です。
う順漢字点だぞ。[笑い]
金持ちだからって勉強しないのは
先生1個ましてくれたら1万円あげるよ。
おお。よく見たらこれも待ってるな。悪る悪る悪る悪る。ま
円
みんなうじさんを見うようにうじて
まあね
いただきます。
僕フレンジしか食べないからいらない。
はい、ありがと。
天様マカロニのカプレーゼトマト風です。
すごい。
アムアムアム。
ボナペチ。ボナペチ。
すげえ。
勝負だ。
うどん来るぞ。俺うジ
じ
よし行け。
銃様の敵は1匹のグラスだ。
俺らの勝ちだ。
お、僕の家が潰れたいよ。
じゃあ1枚あげる。
神よ。
あ、ジュースいいな。
じゃあ自販機ごと買ってあげるよ。
え、
パチパチパチパチパチパチパチパチパチパチ。
ジ最高。
あ、そうなんよ。[笑い]
こんないものいつでもいいくらでも買ってあげるよ。うど
ありがとう。
ありがとう。うど。
え、え、え、え、え、えー、え、え、
実はお父さんの会社が倒産してしまって、今日から貧乏生活だ。
僕のお使いはない。
僕の羊はいない。
僕の金迫すとは
私のは貧乏だからパン屋でもらった食パの耳だ。
やだ、やだ、やだ、やだ。お金がないなって。ありえないよ。やだ、やだ。こんなのいらないよ。
ああ、まして
[笑い]
こピンポの生活いらないよ。
いらない。いらないよ。
はい。勘違始め
いらな。あ、消しゴあと
1個だ。
消しゴさないんよ。
もしお金がないって知られたら誰も僕と遊んでくれなくなるんじゃ。いらない。ケ
シゴムゲット。う、
ドち様、また丸にいたしましょうか?
1万円で。
今日、今日は溶けそうだからやめておくよ。
いただきます。
今日はフレンチ。それともりやん。
今日はお腹痛いからご飯食べないんだ。
じゃあもらうね。
行くぞ。それ今日は出羊は
も僕1
人で勝てるからいらないよ。わあ、痛い痛い痛い痛い痛い痛い痛い痛。
あ、自販機。
うろん、今日も買って
分かったよ。買うからみんな遊んでて。
オッケー。
お金ないやん。どうしよう。
えい。きたい。いてて。あれ?
[笑い]
100円だ。100円だ。100円だ。
ブンブンブンブンブンブン。バイクがブンブンブン
な。なんか売り切りだったみたい。レリファストしあげるよ。いい。
ああ。なんだ。くれないのかよ。
帰ろ、帰ろ。ちゅ、チ。
おかり。
もう無理だよ。
そういえば最近うち学校来てないな。
確かに自販機の日以来いないよね。
ま、気にすんな。色々あるんだろ。
すいません。
う、うちのお母様。
うちの順が引きこもって家から出なくなってしまってな。
なんだって?お母様。そしたら我々が助けてみます。
ええ、
でも授業中でしょ。
生徒は私の子供当然です。
あら、
子供が困ったら助ける。それが先生の役目だ。行くぞメラ。
ああ、
お礼をしなきゃ。
お金じゃないんです。私に任せてください。
こちらです。
ああ。
え、なんだこの?貧乏になってる。金持ってるから来てやったのに。これじゃ頼またらきじゃねえか。
あ、お母さん。生徒は生徒同士直接話し合った方がいいと思うので私はこれにて失礼します。
お前ら頼んだぞ。
やっぱりそうだ。やっぱりそうだ。やっぱりそうだ。お金がなかったらみんなに興味持ってもらえない。じ、
うじ、
帰ってよ。
いいからじてきてまた遊ぼうよ。
お金がない僕には何の魅力もないんだ。帰ってよ。帰れ。
俺ら友達だろ。お金なんて関係ないよ。
お金が全てだよ。
ゆとちょっと手伝ってくれ。
おお。ま、任せれよ。え、え、え、え、え、
せーの。
ええ。
うじ、友達はお金じゃない。お金がなくたっていいんだよ。
この家僕のダンボールハウスより豪華なんよ。
いつも優しくしてくれるし、恩返し。
早く一緒に学校行こう。
み、みんな。
[笑い]
おはよう。
うん。うん。
美味しい。行ってきます。
わあ。消しゴムもないな。
[音楽]
来たよ。お、来た、来た、来た、来た。これも、これも、これも、
これを集めれば
0エの完成ないよ。
できた。
いただきます。
番早く食べれた人がおわりできるんだよ。
え、あ、お帰り。
[笑い]
ゼロ円ジュースって知ってる?
水にグミを入れてめちゃくるとジュースになるんよ。
はい。お、
すごい。お金がなくてもジュースが飲めるんだ。
[音楽]
イエー。
俺のボール止めれるかな?
僕ならできるよ。
おら。
じ様。
え、
じ。
お、お父様。
貧乏な生活をさせて済まなかった。だが実は株が当たってお金持ちになったんだ。
ええ、
またあの金持ちの生活に戻ろう。
お父様、実は僕お金がない方が幸せなんじゃないかって気づいたんだ。お金は人を狂るわしまうんだ。
うん。じゅじんそう
だな。そしたらお前にあげようと思ってた
この1億円もいらないよな。
いるいるいるいるいるいるいる。お金が
あれば何でもできるもんね。お金です。
最高
バカラジオのみんなが中テストを特りして
います。問題はこれです。じゃあ3
位点数優ト
番微妙な
1位
17屋根うどち純
お
おお貨物たとも貨物同じとこ第
4位18問たらやっぱ
[笑い]
高卒はちげえわ
駅目は書いたちげえわさ
はてないのお母さんとお父さんにつけます。